The
[Silence]
Sit down.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Tonight
inshall we will have our questions and
answers
after a few words that we will think
about contemplate a few words from our
prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
on the day of judgment
everything
will be made flat again
all of the earth.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
He says that on the day of judgment, the
earth will be stretched flat
and that it will throw up everything
that is inside of it until it is empty
again. Nothing but the dirt, nothing
that is except that which is part of the
earth.
When that happens,
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us that the sun will be brought one mile
away from the earth.
One mile away from the earth.
How is it possible
for a human being to survive such
scorching, scathing heat?
Because our bodies when we are
resurrected by Allah
will be comprised
in a way fit for the physics of the
hereafter.
So my body today, your body, our bodies
here on this earth, they are made fit
and perfect for this earth and its
physics.
But on the day of judgment, a lot of
things will change.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells
us that things will not be the way they
are here on this earth.
People will be resurrected
and instead of walking on their feet,
they will walk on their face.
That rivers will flow without beds.
that a person's sweat and perspiration
will pull up around him until some
people are taken by their sweat of
anxiety and terror to their heads.
How is this possible?
This is possible because our bodies will
be made fit for the hereafter.
And Muslim the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam tells us that the
hellfire, the fire of the hereafter is
70 times hotter than anything ever
experienced on this earth.
How could a human body stand up to such
heat? It can't. But on the day of
judgment, people who were designed for
hell will be given those physics.
And people who were designed for
paradise,
may Allah make us of those people.
People who were designed for paradise
will be given the physics for paradise.
In surah misam asked Allah to see him.
Allah said you cannot see me now
but look at such and such mountain if it
remains stationary
and remains erect then you can see me.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said when
Allah then exposed himself to that
mountain it was turned immediately to
dust.
The human being cannot fathom such a
thing. Imagine looking up
at Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, the one
who has no beginning, no end. Nothing is
him.
How in the world can a person process
such a sight?
But on the day of judgment, the people
of paradise will see Allah.
And our prophet sallall.aii
says in
that Allah will say to the people of
paradise,
would you all more?
The people of paradise, I hope, I pray
that you and I will all be part of this
conversation.
The people of paradise will say to
Allah, "What more could we ask?
You saved us from hell, from damnation.
You gave us everything our hearts
desired.
And you protected us from ever dying or
becoming ill again. What more could we
ask?
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam said,
[Silence]
At that point, Allah will then remove
his veil,
the veil that stands between the people
of paradise and seeing Allah. And people
will then stare up at Allah,
the king of kings, the judge of judges,
the creator,
the magnificent, the illustrious Allah.
And they will not find anything more
pleasureful than that.
People will be able to see Allah from
there. Can we handle that here? No.
But the people of paradise, their bodies
are designed for paradise.
And the people of hell, their bodies are
designed for hell. And so the sun will
be a mile away
and people will start to sweat.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
tells us that there is only one source
of shade on that day.
It is the shade of the throne of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Who will be allowed under that shade?
He says
[Silence]
subhanahu wa ta'ala
that there are seven types of people
that Allah will allow
under the shade of his throne
on the day when there is no shade but is
many of us have heard this narration
before. Correct? Probably most of us I
would if I was a vetan man I would say
probably all of us have heard this
narration.
But how many of us have honestly thought
about
making sure
that I am at least one of these types of
people.
Imagine taking a narration this
and demanding of yourself
that I will not die until I have earned
my place in the shade of Allah.
And then you conduct the rest of your
life based on that determination and
that vow that every decision you make,
you think back.
Is this going to make me one of those
seven types or will this compromise
my
position under the shade of Allah?
Imagine how our lives would change.
Let us review now these seven types of
people. Who can tell us those seven
types? Let's do it together.
What's the first type?
A leader who is just.
It sounds a lot easier than it is. An
imer who is just. Number two
Muslim brother.
And two people who love one another for
the sake of Allah that that love for the
sake of Allah is what joins them and
upon that love they depart one another.
What does that mean? That means that the
only criteria
for this person's love to fester and
grow in my heart is how
adherent he is or she is to the law of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
the more good they become, meaning the
more they embrace the prophet's sunnah,
the more they actualize the Quran, the
more I love them.
And the less they do so, the less I love
them. That is what love for the sake of
Allah is. I don't want anything from the
dunya from them. I don't want their
notoriety.
I don't want their money. It's not
because they're funny or entertaining.
It is because they remind me of Allah
and that is the kind of people I want to
surround myself with. This is love for
the sake of Allah. A third
[Silence]
masid. Listen to the wording.
A man whose heart is tied deeply to the
masid.
And another wording, a man whose heart
hangs in the masid. Imagine that. A man
whose heart, this is the literal
translation, a man whose heart hangs in
the masid.
That means that when he leaves the
masid, he leaves his heart there,
hanging in the masid. He only feels
whole and satisfied and tranquil when he
is in the masid.
And when he leaves the masid, he feels
he is leaving a part of himself
there.
That is a deep love for the masid. But
the word mass and mid in the Arabic
language can either mean the place or
the action
meaning.
[Silence]
And so the word masjid either means the
place of sujud the place of salah or it
means the places of sujud on your body.
Did you brothers know that even the
Muslim who enters the hellfire for some
crime he has committed
that the hellfire is prohibited from
touching or burning the places of sujud
on his or her body? Allahbar.
Allah has prohibited that part of your
body from the hellfire.
Everything else may be punished, but
those seven places on your body, they
belong to Allah. And he will not allow
places that were dedicated to him be
burned by the fire of hell.
Okay, that is three. Another one.
[Arabic recitation]
This fits into this fits into the one
whose heart is connected to the masid
and the one who loves for the sake of
Allah. Yes.
[Silence]
A man who was invited
by a beautiful woman, an attractive
woman
who was a woman of status
and a woman of beauty.
She attempted to seduce him and the only
thing that stopped him was him repeating
to himself, "I fear Allah." Now, does
this go the other way as well? A woman
who rejects the advances of a man? Of
course.
a man, a woman who is attempted to be
seduced,
but their love of Allah bars them and
stands between them and that.
And notice here the wording of the
narration that she is a woman of beauty
and status.
Meaning it's not that she wasn't
attractive to him and it's not that he
was afraid of the social fallout of such
an affair. She was a woman of status.
However, what barred him was that fear
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Very good.
Those are four
Whoever fears standing in front of his
Lord, for him are two gardens.
What about it
in the generalities of it?
a young man or a young woman who grew up
and spent his youth in the obedience of
Allah. This is becoming harder and
harder every day.
Sometimes I look at the you the youth
amongst us. I honestly have respect for
them when I see them come in the masid
and I honestly feel bad for them because
a lot of the things that they face I
didn't grow up facing
this internet and pictures and and the
most wicked and vile of things being at
the tips of your fingers.
It is truly a miracle from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala that a young man, a
young woman would find it in themselves
in this environment to walk into the
house of Allah. That's an incredible
choice and that earns the person a
position in the shade of Allah.
Now what's the
A person reaches the height of his youth
and begins to veer into becoming
older above the age of youth at 33 years
old. Some scholars mention 25 years old.
However, 33 is the time when a person
Now he is no longer youth. He is a
complete adult in every sense of the
word from the age of puberty which is 13
14 at the latest 15 years old to the age
of 33. Now so these how many are these?
You're supposed to be keeping
[Arabic recitation]
taking down the minutes here. Five.
Two more.
[Arabic recitation]
Okay, hold it. I'm going to call on you
next.
He says,
"A man who remembers Allah, remembers
Allah what? Read in the Quran. Even if
his lips don't move, Allah comes to his
mind, to his heart, and his eyes flow
with tears. A mixture of emotions, love,
fear, honor,
all of these things,
and his eyes flow and well up. This is a
person who is you know oftent times
secularists and materialists and
atheists they will say things you
know religion is so silly. Why would why
would God the creator worry about
something so small as what you eat or
what you put in into your stomach or or
what you do or say. It's not about size.
It's not about how big I am. that means
I'm more important and if I'm smaller
I'm less important.
It's about pressure,
free will, intellect and revelation all
meeting together and producing something
that all of the angels together could
not produce. A tear that flows and drops
from the eye of a believer.
These tears extinguish the flames of
hell.
Okay, one more. Is it one more? One
more. Right.
[Silence]
and a man. And all of these are
statements. A man, a man, a man. All of
these are unisex.
In proper speech, you have to choose a
sex. Especially in the Arabic language,
it is either male or female. Everything
is. And a man who gave in charity.
And he was so secret with it. It was so
much for the sake of Allah that not even
his left hand knew what his right hand
was giving.
These are seven people, seven types.
There is not one Muslim amongst us who
cannot be one or more of these seven
types.
Which one is it? You know, oftent times
when we ask a person, if you were to ask
a person, you know, let's say a young
man growing up and going to school, what
are you going to be when you grow up?
Well, I want to be a doctor. Okay. How
are you going to do how are you going to
become a doctor? They have a detailed
plan. A detailed plan of how they're
going to become a doctor. I'm going to
do this and this grade and every single
paper and assignment has a meaning to
it. everything I do or don't do, my
attendance has something to do with
this. Then I graduate, I'm going to
apply to this college and I'm going to
do this. They have a plan, a detailed
plan. And then you ask the same person,
how are you going to Jenna? They said,
well, inshallah, you know, I'm just
going to be good. That's it. I'm just
going to be good. That's it.
The lack of detail in our plans for the
hereafter is what makes most of us
wander wander off of the path.
We're not detailed. We we've got this
general idea of yeah, Jenna, but
it's kind of a pie in the sky thing and
you know, probably at the end of my
life, I'm going to try to work a little
bit harder, but I'm just generally going
to be good. That's no way to get
somewhere. You have to just if you
want to travel somewhere, you have to
have a detailed moment by moment,
blowby-blow, junction byjunction plan
and map. You need the same thing to get
to Jenna. The same thing.
And so what is your plan? How are you
going to get there? You begin with the
steps that Allah began with in the
Quran.
Those are your steps onto the path. Then
what is your map? What's your plan? What
is your blowby-blow junction by
junction? How are you getting there? Are
you going to be one of these seven? How
are you going to do it? Are you which
how many gates for paradise? Eight. Each
gate designated to those who are
excellent in one type of worship of
Allah. The gate of jihad, the gate of
salah, the gate of the parents, the gate
of fasting, the gate of charity. Every
one of those eight gates has a person, a
type of excellence that a person will be
admitted to paradise through. Which one
are you? Which one have you decided to
be?
My thing that I'm good at is knowledge.
That's what I'm good at. I might not be
good at a lot of other things, but this
is something I'm good at and it goes it
flows in my blood and it's in my it's in
my bones.
We all have to have one of those things
at least one. Abu Bakr Sadik asked the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam when he
told him about the gates of paradise.
eight gates of paradise. He said, "Oh
messenger of Allah, is there anybody who
will be allowed through more than one of
those gates?" Meaning they will be
invited. Imagine there are angels at
each gate. These angels are inviting the
people of this gate in. The prophet
sallall.aii
said that the gates of paradise from one
side of the door to the other is 40
years travel
and it will be mustered together of
people trying to enter through those
gates.
And so the the angels at those gates are
inviting people come through this gate,
come through that gate. And so Abu Bakr
asked, "Is anybody going to be invited
through more than one of those gates?"
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
that Abu Bakr
would be invited through all eight gates
of paradise.
That means that he was excellent
at everything that he stood to do for
the sake of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
That's the kind of men that were around.
The kind of women that were around the
messenger Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam. Those are our forefathers.
Those are our ancestors. You and I.
Those are our ancestors.
They didn't play games. They didn't kick
footballs around and sit around and make
vines and videos and laugh and stick
their tongues out. They had the place to
go. They're not from here. This dunya
was not theirs. We're not from here.
We're just passing through. They were on
a mission. Didn't mean that their life
wasn't joyous. Their life was good. It
was worthy. They had something to die
for. And so they lived for something
because they had something to die for.
So having said that we will take a few
questions inshallah
if there are any questions.
Okay. Going once, going twice. Yes sir.
Brother Well
from Moratania. I was I almost said
brother well from me. Yes.
[Arabic recitation]
with us what is your favorite hadith and
why?
[Arabic recitation]
I I can't say that there's a favorite
hadith. Every breath our messenger took
is more beloved to me than all of my
kids and my everything that I own. But I
will tell you this,
there's an narration that I heard once
from a scholar of hadith in a class and
that scholar has since passed away
a great from Egypt and he mentioned this
hadith and I was a student of hadith at
the time and I drove myself up a wall
trying to find this narration.
It was so bad that I even resorted to
looking on the internet, which is real
bad if you could push me to look for a
narration on the internet. And I spent
actually a number of years trying to
find this narration. I wanted to find
it. And I finally found it in Muslim.
I'll share with you what this narration
says. The prophet sallall.aii
Wasam said that there will be men and
women who come at the end of time.
A person amongst them will love the
prophet Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam so
much that he will wish that he could
trade all of his wealth and all of his
family for one look upon the prophet's
face. Sallallah.aii wasallam. I mean
imagine that right
that a person loves our prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam so much that if
they were to say you see my kids all of
them I love my children. I love my
family. I love my wife. I love my wealth
my success everything. But if they were
given the bargain to we will give you
one look,
one look.
But the cost is everything you have. You
will return to zero. They will do it.
And that is an incredible amount of love
for the prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
And honestly, that was a narration that
really
it really had a lot of impact on my
life, a lot of impact on on my my my
time throughout my 20s and 30s. So,
now there's so many, you know, but
that's one that sticks out.
Any other questions?
Brother is Hak here. Yes.
We've got a couple minutes left.
[Arabic recitation]
in the queue of prayers and you
remembered the ablution you performed
before was with socks.
[Arabic recitation]
ablution you just use the water to
sprink on the socks.
[Arabic recitation]
and you're in a queue of prayers to
pray.
[Arabic recitation]
you performed before was with socks and
right now you have no socks on your
legs.
[Arabic recitation]
the question. A person makes woo and
then they put on their socks, whatever
they are, leather socks, boots, whatever
it is that they're going to make wipe
over. They go through their day. They
break their woo. They make woo again and
wipe over their footwear
and then they take those socks off.
How does that affect a person's woo?
This will not invalidate a person's woo.
We've mentioned there are six things
that will invalidate a person's wudoo in
the most generous of opinions. Really,
it's only four things that will break a
person's woo. and taking off your socks
or shoes is not one of those things. The
correct opinion amongst the scholarship
of Islam is that the woodoo
is what is connected to the footwear not
breaking the wudoo. So what does that
mean? That means that if a person puts
on his socks, let's say, and he has,
well, Louie puts on his socks, he goes
through the day,
the time for one day for the resident,
three days for the traveler, that starts
when when they wipe over their socks the
first time.
That's when it starts.
Let me give you an example. Let's say a
person, what this means is there's a
time limit on a person's footwear.
One day
and one night for a resident
three days and three nights as Ali
mentioned as
mentioned and others of the companions
and three nights and days for the
traveler. Meaning after one day and
night complete day and night you have to
take them off and make wudoo again
complete wudoo. Same thing for the
traveler 3 days with their nights. Now
the time is finished you have to take
off the socks and remake the wudoo
completely. Okay. But when does that
start? Does it start with your first woo
before you put them on? Does it start
when you break your woo? or does it
start when you first wipe over those
socks? The answer is it starts the first
time you wipe over those socks and woo.
Let's say I wake up, I make a full woo,
put my socks on at I make
I go until I make and then I break my
woo at
then the time for comes. I make woo and
then wipe over my socks for
when do I have to take those socks off
again and make to make woo again
the next day not
the next day because the time starts
with the first wiping over the socks.
Okay. Now the question is what breaks
the wuboo?
The breaking of the wuboo is not
connected to the socks at all. What's
connected to the socks is making wudoo.
Right?
So I make woodoo. I put on my socks for
I make I break my wudoo after comes
around. I make wudoo. I wipe over my
socks.
Comes around. It was muddy outside.
Whatever. I take them off to come into
the masid and pray. I still have udoo. I
still have woodoo until I break woodoo.
Again, what I cannot do is put the socks
on again and wipe over them. Now I have
to make full woo. Again, taking the
socks off does not break a person's woo.
This was a point of contention for Ahmed
in his earlier days. He was of the
opinion that taking the socks off breaks
a person's woo. At the end of his med
and what he fell into agreement with
with the other scholars of his time is
that the time is elapsed based on
wiping. But taking the socks off does
not break a person's wudoo. Let's say I
take the socks off at right. I made woo
at I wiped over them comes. I take the
socks off. I put the socks back on and
then I make
and then the next day comes and I need
to make woo. Now I have to take my socks
off to make wudoo again. But I did not
break my woo by merely removing the
socks and wiping over the socks and the
footwear. That's a whole can of worms
we're going to have to tackle one of
these days inshallah. There's a lot of
questions about it. It's a little bit
detailed. So, we will try to do that
maybe next week or something. But very
good question. It's clear clear answer.
Yes,
[Arabic recitation]
Why? We have narrations of Omar Salisha,
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
himself. All of them were authentically
narrated to have wiped over cotton
socks, specifically cotton socks. Right.
Inshallah, we'll try to talk about this
next week. Jazak, thank you for your
patience. May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
bless us all. We ask Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to make this gathering and all of
our gatherings in this blessed masid a
place where the angels attend to hear
the words of Allah and the words of his
messenger. We ask Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to make us of those whom he is
think he is speaking of right now today
as we are speaking of him subhanahu wa
ta'ala. We ask Allah to give give us and
bless us through the verses of the Quran
and the words and breaths of his
messenger Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam.
We ask Allah that he raise the mention
of our messenger in the greatest of
gatherings in the greatest of stages of
the heavens and that he gather us with
Allah with the messenger sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam and his companions and
the righteous on the day of judgment
under the banner of ham and praise of
Allah.
early.